there he is mr. ed my let how you doing
man
I'm good brother how are you look at
that view man can you see it
yeah yeah yeah it comes in and out of
focus but I can see it it looks great
gorgeous yeah it's a beautiful day a
little cold so I'm a little bit buttoned
up but it's all good I'm in Toronto
Canada man so cold there's a whole new
level
[Laughter]
one of my favourite cities on earth
that's like one of the most beautiful
modern great cities in the world so by
the way I want to tell you one thing
here uh your content is so good that's
why I'm I mean I'll I found you is your
content obviously did some stuff on me
but you produce some of the best stuff
out there I appreciate that man I've
been diving into your world and the
Stephanie McMahon interview that you did
yeah was fire thank you yeah I love that
one yeah ah she's amazing woman and the
one you did with David Meltzer sitting
sitting basically looks like the same
view like you're sitting on the beach
there there that's we're sitting looking
out at this don't know if you can see it
or not but that's where that's where we
sat day or the night so for my audience
who may not be as familiar with with
what you're up to at my let mr. max out
had a huge success as entrepreneur and
now is on a mission to inspire motivate
people to live their best lives we did a
top 10 on him that was fire and looking
forward to featuring more of your stuff
but you you know I'm curious why why
this you know like you've had so much
success you had your financial success I
know you're back and what you came from
and you've turned it around and such an
amazing story
why now spend this the I think when you
go to the second chapter of your life
spending now giving back and helping
people look what motivated that that's a
great question the conversation started
with Tony Robbins so Tony's a friend of
mine and and you know kind of knew I've
been speaking on stage and stuff for a
long time and just said hey listen you
know this space needs some people that
have real content and I don't mean that
negatively to anybody who else is in the
space but there are a lot of guys repeat
themselves over and over and over and I
don't know man
here's the truth I asked myself this all
the time I'm doing seven podcast today
I'm recording three shows of my own
tomorrow and there was a point in time
in my life were a day like today I'd
probably just be sitting on this movie
it's each and now those you know that
sort of gone by the wayside I think the
answer is this I really do love people I
love helping people and I didn't get to
where I am alone I'm not that bright of
a guy I'm not dumb but I'm not high IQ
I'm not incredibly gifted or talented I
really had a series of mentors enter my
life most of which all at the right time
that helped me get to next levels and
stretch my vision and think bigger and
course-correct me and so I just feel
like I spent the first half of my life
kind of building my dream and kind of my
resume and I want to spill the second
half of my life spend it helping other
people build their dream in their resume
and so I love it I mean it's not work to
me
I'm enjoyed this time this last couple
years more than any two years of my
entire life just because I've got to
know all kinds of different people and
fall in love with people in a way that I
didn't I didn't have before I was just
sort of a private rich dude so I'm
loving it what was the first thing that
you did that's it okay I'll give this a
shot was it a speech or a video what
happened well I've been speaking for a
really really long time but what it
really was it was actually a
confrontation and a good one we were on
my balcony and Tony said hey you need to
get into space I said look man I like
this but I like that I can go into a
restaurant and not everybody knows me
right I'm gonna cuss right now it's like
everybody permission but I just want to
say this he said to me he goes that's
why you're loser
hmm look kind of grab me at my fire pit
right and I go what he goes well you say
you want help all these people but you
don't really want to inconvenience
yourself to do it at all so you really
want to help everybody and I'm like you
know what and my son was just to get
your phone how you do this Instagram
thing I'm not kidding you like a blah
blah blah click one of those hash browns
on there and post this thing and like I
should have been hashtags and I had
three followers that was a year I was a
year this past May was a year planned so
it's almost like a challenge thing and
then all of a sudden I started getting
responses it you know how it is you get
a message from somebody that says hey
what you said really affected me or tell
me at the right time you know
this goes because you're in this space
and when you really feel like oh my gosh
I helped another human because there's
I'll just tell you if there's everyone
has multiple needs Tony teaches us I
teach this there's six human needs and
when you're young one of the dominant
needs you should have is to be
significant is to be recognized is to
win is to want to be somebody and I'll
never lose that all achievers have that
I want to win thing but there does
become a point in your life where that
doesn't fulfill you anymore and you can
shift the contribution and contribution
is a need that will never be completely
fulfilled you'll never get overwhelming
that you'll never have enough
contribution and so I've sort of shifted
I'm a significance do believe me it's
not it's by no mistake the oceans in the
background here right like yeah see
you'll see videos with my jet but I'm
not like other dudes probably other
things where I'm like addicted to those
things I know for a fact I want
everybody in here to have a jet or live
on the ocean or live on the lake I want
you to have that because it's wonderful
don't anybody tell you it's not but I
also know for a fact it'll make you
happy but it will not fulfill you it'll
be temporary happiness there's a big
difference in temporary happiness and
long-term fulfilment long-term
fulfillment is contribution and so like
this is the stage of my life I've been
the most fulfilled so very quickly I got
addicted to the feeling of helping
people and it hasn't ended yet so that
was sort of the genesis of it was a
challenge by Tony and then me following
love with what I hopefully I can do
sometimes for other people so this is
actually something I I think about too
because I just came back from Tony's
thing in New Jersey like last weekend
yeah what did you think of it I'm just
curious good event huh yeah I mean I've
been I've been before when it was in LA
but this time Tony brought me as a
special guest and like sitting in the
front row is a totally different
experience how do you know the thing
that you're doing is actually
contribution and you're not tricking
yourself that it's still not significant
so he and I just talked about this
that's like I was talking to rob dyrdek
about this who's been one of the guests
on my show and ridiculousness and he
hosts ridiculous and also very
successful entrepreneur and this is
amazing you asked this because I'm I'm
wondering this very thing myself still
and so
when I met Rob I said dude you're a
contribution guy the way talked to my
camera crew how much he loves to help
I'll go your contribution and then
significance right and then we went to a
Rams game a few weeks ago hey bro I've
been sick I just want you to know I'm
not I'm significant contribution I'm
still a significance guy and so right
after that I went to Abu Dhabi I was
with Tony over there for about eight
days and I said that to him too and I
still think probably I'm a significant
person but now then this is important
distinction I get my significance from
contributing I used to get my
significance from stuff winning
achievement money what people thought
about me you know the jet and by the way
I still get some of it that way but now
the way I feel the most significant is
by contributing to others and so I
probably am a significance person
contribution and it's funny Rob and I
are at the the Rams game and he goes
littlest guys we know and he goes Tom
Brady significance contribution Sly
Stallone significance contribution Tony
Robbins significance contribution right
we start listing mega achievers and we
both kind of came to the conclusion that
probably the best combination for the
most fulfilled people is their
significant contribution people and so I
ma puce best question honest to god
that's the best question anybody's asked
me cuz I'm struggling with how I want to
frame that and reference it about myself
right now and I think you're right it's
probably significance and then
contribution so Tony has you go through
what your two things are and I had
growth as my second so I had significant
contribution as a joint one and I think
last year was probably like sixty
percent significance and forty percent
contribution and I feel like this year I
flipped it some 60 percent contribution
forty percent significance yeah but I
know that I can never get to zero like
maybe it's ninety ten is like an ideal
State ninety percent contribution but
there's still about ten percent
significance okay say something on that
cuz like yeah I didn't know we would
talk about something probably this
profound but I've gone through all kinds
of that with myself like is it that
unhealthy to want significance right and
I even went all the way I mean this is
extreme and I'm not telling you I've
thought this all the way through so
anybody holding this but I went all the
way through almost people would say is
the ultimate contributor in Jesus the
Jesus
to lack all significance I mean he did
say I am the Messiah I am the truth
right I mean I don't I think they say
that even the greatest contributors
didn't have any significance element I'm
not talking about humility humility is
different you can be a big significance
person and still be humble right I think
all great leaders have some significance
in there I just do I don't think it's
something to avoid and I and I'm no
longer trying to act like I'm elevated
beyond being and somebody who's into
significance and let me say this if in
any way Tony's trying to say he's not
after significance he's not being honest
either right but I think even Tony being
oz is a big-time significance person he
can't get through it Bob just leave it
there he likes significance in a good
way and yeah the way his desire to gain
significance he's changed millions of
other people's lives and I'd like right
but that's what I'm doing as well so
kind of cool I appreciate your
perspective on it managing something
I've been thinking about you've got your
podcasts you've got your YouTube you've
got your Instagram it's been blowing up
you know I've been doing I've been doing
my channel it's 10 years November I had
my channel so it's been a decade of this
graduation thanks man
and and like you seem to come out of
nowhere it's like it was nothing and
then hey as my let you gotta follow at
my let make my let so you kind of burst
onto the scene and I love it like what's
the next thing that you're focused on is
it like I want to keep just doing more
of what I'm doing is it's still just a
podcast Instagram YouTube you're gonna
well where do you see yourself going oh
I have a program now called RFA
syndicate that I've partnered with Andy
Priscilla on it's a one of them it's
called The Syndicate it's a live
mentoring program pretty expensive where
people talk with us every week and we
meet once a quarter and I'm doing that
so I'm actually engaged directly in
their lives then we created another
program called the RFA accelerator it's
just a few hundred dollars a month but
every week they're on a call with me or
Andy and then we have live meetings from
time to time as well Facebook group and
so I'm working with those folks too so
I'm engaging a little beyond the podcast
in terms of my show too you know in all
candor I've got anything done but I've
had discussions with Netflix
some other people about taking my show -
perhaps a another platform or a bigger
platform but what I do want to do is I'm
creating a program right now I just
wrote my book mapped out your life which
we've sold about seven hundred thousand
copies of so thanks for a significant by
the way I'm not pitching this either
it's totally free you can just go to max
outt book calm and put in the code max
out the books free and there's no upsell
afterwards it's not like click here
buy my book and then get it seminar it's
just a free book so you can go get that
and so I'm just trying to start to
create more and more content that
affects people and find the best mediums
to do it and frankly the reason that I
think my stuff has grown and I'm not
trying to be braggadocious in this
regard my contents good like my content
and stuff that can really affect you and
change you I'm not gonna tell you 1,100
times it gets you money I'm not gonna
tell you to be kind 1,100 times and just
repeat myself or binary and all this
stuff the guys's keep repeating
themselves it's just it's mindless
information I don't even understand how
they have following to be honest with
you it's like I've heard you say this
same thing 2,000 different times whereas
I'm trying to keep my content fresh
relevant and spur ational but also
strategic that's not knocking people
just I think you do this very well like
if you're gonna be in the space really
bring value to people you know I mean if
people are gonna follow you give them
value and inspiration for the the
privilege of them following you so I
feel an obligation to try to create
stuff daily when I can to move someone's
life forward and so I feel like I wanted
to be like this like people that follow
me feel like man I get to talk to him
every day just a little bit and so
that's sort of been the genesis of it
and I've my goal just so you know my
goal is I want to reach a hundred
million people the next three years with
my stuff and so I've got a lot of work
to do and I've been talking to different
people in the space I've talked to Grant
Cardone I've talked to Andy I thought
the Tony Robbins like what's the best
way to to get this stuff out there
that's in an unconventional fashion
other than just Instagram other than
just you know YouTube there's got to be
better venues and maybe Netflix is that
place for me I'm not sure I would love
to see even do bigger on YouTube man I'd
like help me to be honest with you on
lost there I don't know what
do I don't know how to promote it we
just sort of stick my stuff up there
where I really do well because my
contents long so I do well on one-minute
videos on Instagram because I'm pretty
good at getting a message out in a
minute and my audios do very well maybe
that's cuz I'm not pleasant to look at
and my voice is okay right but I think
the other part of it is just my contents
an hour long I think perhaps that
affects people wanting to watch a video
for an hour but I would love because
you're a YouTube guru I would love you
to mention me on that cuz I don't know
what I'm doing on YouTube so I'd love
your information on that anything you
could tell me
yeah man listen I'm happy to happen we
can take this offline with me or you and
your team but my last video my channel
is 40 minutes long like long is great if
it's good right and you and I know you
have good stuff it's something I'm
talking about like Tony's same thing he
needs to be going long he like his stuff
is forever long yeah but but you can win
you can like YouTube is the place to go
long
yeah and you can you could really crush
it wow this is good for other people get
a lot of people that are listen to this
great content want to know how to get
out there too and so I'm gonna pick your
brain about that that's a big clue for
everyone watching this I learned from
everybody so you're you're better at
getting traffic on YouTube to me why in
the world would I not humble myself and
get everything I can learn from you
possibly and so I'm we're going to do
that so thank you I'd love to see you in
harder man's like thank you
most people can make long videos but
they repeat themselves a hundred times
and not saying anything where I know
you've got like a lot of depth to it
which you can really crush that how do
you feel about people stopping in a
restaurant now you know what I were
wonderful I did have you know there's
things that come with it I had someone
yesterday show up at my home scared my
family don't ever do that by the way
everybody I mean you see someone in a
restaurant that's wonderful you don't go
to someone's home so I love it and and
and I think anybody who tells you that
they're bothered by the attention they
get from other beautiful souls as an ego
problems a tad honestly matters it's a
wonderful thing for me sometimes like
well I can't believe people listen to me
you know and and and so I'm grateful for
any positive I'm actually grateful for
any interaction
even if I've had people give me feedback
that you know I I interviewed Rachel
Hollis boom oh yeah great I adore her
right and we had such an amazing
interview and it got several hundred
thousand audio downloads and I had a few
people message me say hey he referred to
her as precious in the interview don't
refer to a woman as precious I'm like my
god my wife's precious my daughter's
precious my mom's precious you know so
it wasn't really feedback I enjoyed
hearing but it was like feedback so like
okay if that bothers somebody I'll watch
it I can't please everybody
so I even like interaction with people
when it's not positive but I love
walking into the gym I just left the gym
you know it's hard to get a workout in
now but I love walking into a place and
people say thank you because that's the
main thing that I get in that you get
you know what it usually is just thank
you thank you thank you and then
typically like can I tell you how you've
helped me what is wonderful to hear and
then typically a question right then one
question and I'm glad to answer any
question I can for somebody so I love it
and I've had the benefit brother of the
last 20 years you know this maybe the
audience doesn't know it I sort of have
been blessed that where I lived prior to
me being relatively well known most of
my friends have been well known people
so I've watched my friends actors and
athletes the last 20 years how they
handle it and the ones that are gracious
and the ones that aren't and I've
watched a few of them handle it poorly
where I thought you know the rest of
that person's life they're gonna
remember that encounter with you that
wasn't good and then I have other
friends who are wonderful with each and
every single person and I learned from
that and then the other thing is this
you usually get the best version of
somebody hmm
I usually get the best version of that
person because they're happy to meet me
so what a blessing from God that I could
see the best in almost every single
person so I love it
what if I'm really interested in that is
is Tony called you out because that was
something that you thought would be an
inconvenience to you but it ends up
being a massive blessing the reason is
is that he knows how introverted I am so
I have people say don't admit you're shy
don't admit you're introverted that's
not your last it's totally true I'm an
introverted person I'm a private person
I'm shy
I've worked on those things those aren't
it's not Who I am its behaviors that I
have and so he knew intuitively if he
didn't give me massive pain you know the
pain pleasure stuff they said hey you
should really consider you're pretty
good speaker getting out there in public
I'd be like I considered it know what he
did right with the massive pain gave me
a massive dose of pain I was I don't
like that and so he knew he needed to go
that way because of my my proclivity to
be introverted so it was great well I
love that how sometimes the things that
we think are the biggest inconvenience
end up being the best blessings
absolutely man almost every single time
I effect I posted a speech today that I
gave to I want I got invited back to
speak to my college alma mater spaceball
if you know played college baseball the
university of pacific and i went back
there and spoke to the guys and there's
a part in the talk where I tell them
that I was so introverted my senior year
I wasn't gonna graduate and I had to
take two electives so I was gonna
graduate and I got I had previously
dropped out of a sign language class
sign language because I had to go up in
front of the class and sign it was I
didn't even speak I just wouldn't walk
up there move my fingers around and I
dropped the class and so it put me where
I wasn't gonna graduate and so the only
class I could take to graduate was drama
and public speaking and I had to take
them both and in the public speaking
class I found a giftedness of mine right
and so what you're saying is completely
true I talked about in this speech
typically on the other side of your
greatest fear of your greatest
insecurity is your greatest blessing
everyone goes well get out of your
comfort zone you'll find an enema where
you're afraid of and what you're
insecure about on the other side of that
is typically one of the great gifts or
blessings in your life and so that's
exactly right you and I are talking
right now because I took a public
speaking class my senior year I was
stone ass afraid of in college that's
why you and I are talking right now so
you're 11 right and how many people been
touched now because of you taking that
class and a mutual right and somehow
that blessing that's seemingly
inconsequential scary pain in the ass
for me changed my entire life and has
changed frankly millions of other
people's lives because I went around
that thing I was afraid of it's like you
don't even know the magnitude of what
it's costing you to get into your fears
and insecurities and by the way
insecurities and fears are different
things they're both really insidious
detrimental things that people struggle
with and so on the other side of your
fear that's one thing and on the other
side of your greatest insecurity our
blessing and you have no idea that
immeasurable waves that you're missing
in your life because you are giving in
to them and cowering to them and so it's
like my life totally different take me a
little deeper there what's the
difference between fear and security
well fear is something that as you stare
at it there's a reaction in your body
that's actually healthy it's to protect
you with fear in and our nature because
way back in the day this is how we
survive right so here is not an
unhealthy thing what it is is it's an
alert to you that hey there's something
here you need to be more aware of here
is an awareness emotion what most people
think is it's an avoidance emotion fear
is to make you aware right so I had a
little fear in an odd way when my
daughter was being born when my son was
being more I wasn't afraid of having a
daughter it was an awareness of all the
great things that could come with it and
my fear of what could go wrong that day
right so thank God my daughter was born
so that fear wasn't some sign it
shouldn't happen or shouldn't go through
with it it was a hyper awareness
insecurity is a lie you tell yourself
insecurity is completely different
insecurity is mainly things that don't
exist that you should not be aware of so
on ironically people conflate these two
things and insecurity is something that
you've told yourself that is more than
likely a lie about you I'm stupid I'm
short nobody loves me no one's going to
listen to me I'm not strong enough
I'm gonna blow this right what are they
going to think about me these are all
fabrications of your imagination fear is
a real thing that you should acknowledge
and see and respond to favorably
insecurities are lies and so on it most
people don't make that distinction
and they actually think their
insecurities are things they should be
aware of when in fact insecurities are
things you should not be aware of
totally different thing by the way you
should be we should be selling this
content right now this is good I'm
looking forward to that too
two one-hour YouTube video or you know I
only dive super deep on it I'm so sick
now right you're reading my mind oh okay
it's cool man it's crazy how quickly
time flies and now we're bumping up
against the clock for my audience if
they want to dive deeper into your world
what's the best place to start oh boy
I'm right here Instagram and then go to
my podcast on iTunes you can subscribe
to my youtube channel Evans gonna help
me grow that so it's coming and I've got
a website at my let com I do put out
newsletters there where I do some of the
stuff but here's the deal man a lot of
people don't read right now and so what
I do is I do a lot of the reading for
you and then I'll send you out a
newsletter with the summation about what
I'm reading and if you just read my
email you'll be reading some of the
books I've been reading too so you can
go to my website too so I think by the
way thanks for today man I enjoyed it
very much
love it man thanks to make the time
really appreciate it and we'll connect
again soon I want you looking forward to
that take care thanks ed seriously
also if you want to know what I think
and what other successful entrepreneurs
think about building confidence check
out my new to 54 confidence series where
every day for the next two hundred fifty
four days for free I will send you a 30
second a five minute video in the
morning to help you build unstoppable
confidence the link is in the
description below if you want to be more
confident you need to surround yourself
with things that make you feel confident
realizing that any big endeavor is the
collection of a lot of small steps that
came before if you're doing work that
you loved you're more likely to follow
through you're more likely to do it
because it doesn't feel like work
because you love doing it if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you up or it would
be like a little beacon if you want more
ed my let check out the top ten rules
video I made on him the link is right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I had some health issues when I
was younger with my heart I am grateful
many mornings I wake up